sebastian stellt vanilleeis wie die
industrie her zum einsetzen eines
experten für industriell hergestelltes
eis
sein dann kann
mit fett und zucker kreiert liege ein
eis wie von langnese
[Musik]
das kennen wir doch alle und genau diese
tafel wer stand im freibad noch nicht in
der schlange und hat da drauf gstaad
geguckt das möchte ich jetzt fruchtig
creme ich schokolade ich
habe ganze
trovan einst einer
der klassiker ist schon seit den
sechzigern im sortiment das ist eiscreme
in knackiger schokolade mit lustigen
stückchen drin wer das nicht kennen und
es gibt es heute noch
schmeckt es auch noch genau so gut wie
früher im schwimmbad
was ist so künstlich weisner
[Musik]
habe ich mir jetzt können die gedanken
darüber gemacht aber heute
sebastian liegen in diesem eis stecken
einige tricks
[Musik]
sie gleichermaßen über locker weg nur an
der reform und das langnese eis
schlechthin ordnung ist das etwas
besonderes
irgendwie immer das gleiche
cremiges eis knackige schokolade um
wollen sie wissen warum die das so
machen da kommen sie mal mit cornetto
und magnum oder via nova oder eiskonfekt
bei seinen beliebtesten sorten versteckt
langnese das eis unter einer schokoladen
hülle sebastian liege will in düsseldorf
herausfinden warum das so ist
macht glücklich malte wienbreyer findet
ja das tut es aber nur wenn man es mit
besten zutaten und der nötigen geduld
herstellt
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich dir mal umso vanille zu
setzen
und das wasser an schwarzen pünktchen
ist dass ich
weiß woran ich das erinnert an die
weihnachtsplätzchen meiner großmutter
das ist ein kompliment die
haben genauso geschmack ich wüsste ich
können die augen zu machen und um hilfe
schrie vor mir und gibt mir dieses noch
leicht warm
butterplätzchen was die gemacht aber ich
habe diese plätzchen gelegt geschmack
ist erinnerung neben an das labor hat
dann geht man rein kommt
die basis für sein vanille milcheis hat
der eismacher bereits am vortag
angesetzt literweise sahne hat er mit
zucker aufgekocht und dann über nacht
ruhen lassen durch dieses reifen kann
sich der geschmack optimal entwickeln
[Musik]
das ist jetzt ein ganz eigentlich ein
süß schmeckende milch speise das ist
genau wie süß schmeckende das ist so die
die basis für ein richtiges milch
sondern ein klassisches milchreis der
geschmack sehr gut
gold
damit daraus vanilleeis wird braucht
malte wienbreyer nur noch eine besonders
feine zutat stadt vanilleschoten nutzt
er vanille essenz bei dem die aromen der
vanille mit alkohol aus den schulden
heraus gelöst wurden
[Musik]
eine pure vanille ist
vorteil im vergleich zu echten schoten
die aromen der essenz sind
hochkonzentriert und praktisch
unbegrenzt haltbar
den rest der arbeit erledigt die
eismaschine in wenigen minuten
verwandelt sie die sahne zucker
vermischen in cremiges vanilleeis besten
natürlichen zutaten
[Musik]
was kostet die kugel vanilleeis
zurzeit glaube ich 173
liter kostet hochwertiges vanilleeis aus
der eisdiele rund 28 euro und
damit ein vielfaches von die retter das
gut drei euro pro liter kostet lokal
liegt bei 5 euro 30
selbst eiskonfekt kostet mit 16 euro pro
liter nur etwas mehr als die hälfte für
die preise selbst langnese auf günstige
zutaten so malte
vorbei mit der romantik jetzt bin ich
mal gespannt immer den ganzen aufwand
die nur betreiben können wir zwar jetzt
kommen die alchemisten so
sauber das ist mein vanilleeis
sebastian lege vermeidet teure sahne er
setzt auf 0,5 prozentige mager milch und
billiges pflanzenfett
[Musik]
kokosfett und schüssel
der produktentwickler schmilzt das fett
und stellt eine art künstliche sonne her
kokosfett ist wichtig für den schmelz
für die cremigkeit bei dir es ja sahne
drin viel zu teuer für industriell
hergestelltes eis
kokosfett ist dagegen sehr günstig
erzählt aber viele ungesunde gesättigte
fettsäuren
und jetzt auch meist ist letztlich das
glück das flüssige kokosfett hier ein
das heißt ich habe auch gleich das feld
an der stelle wo sein will wie war diese
frist
dies wird immer dicker wird
immer dicker und dicker machen dass
geschmacksneutral für geschmack sorgte
im industrie es jede menge puderzucker
und klebriger glukosesirup der sorgt für
süße
glanz und haltbarkeit
[Musik]
dann lohne und ihn zur rede von speisen
fettsäuren sorgt dafür dass alles sich
immer perfekt verbindet
auch mal ein bisschen weil
das reicht auch schon parallel auch
unter clijsters der sorgt dafür dass
alles zu einer gelartigen konsistenz
würden künstlich ist vanille aroma
[Musik]
schmeckt natürlich sind vanille
geschmack also das geht schon in
richtung die richtung sag ich mal so es
geht ihm aber es geht wirklich nur in
die richtung schmeißt die maschine
dieselbe eismaschine gefüllt mit ganz
anderen zutaten als bei nebel ein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
guck doch mal bitte an wie das aussieht
[Musik]
sieht aus wie softeis ja
sebastian lege hat die eismassen
nachgeburt die etwa so in wien ett
unlocker eiskonfekt und vielen weiteren
langnese sorgen steckt weitgehend ohne
das umstrittene palmöl
[Musik]
unilever setzt stattdessen auf kokosfett
doch das ist aus umweltsicht alles
andere als einen fortschritt denn auch
kokospalmen wachsen auf riesigen
plantagen für die immer wieder
wertvoller regenwald abgeholzt wird
und kokospalmen bringen viel weniger
ertrag auf einem hektar kann fünfmal
mehr palmöl als kokosfett gewonnen
werden
dementsprechend fällt auch die
umweltbilanz von kokosfett erheblich
schlechter aus als die von palmfett
es gibt aber auch natürlich heimische
fette die deutlich nachhaltiger wären
zum beispiel rapsöl kann auch in
deutschland angebaut werden und hat
deswegen gar nicht diesen transportweg
und es dadurch deutlich nachhaltiger
mit den vorwürfen konfrontiert schreibt
der konzern unilever hat sich
unternehmensweit zu einer entwaldung
freien lieferkette für unsere
wichtigsten nutzpflanzen bis 2023
verpflichtet am kokosfett will unilever
allerdings festhalten weil es
entscheidend zu guten konsistenz und dem
besonderen mundgefühl beiträgt
alles nur weil unilever teure sahne
ersetzen will heraus kommt ein eis das
die experten nicht sonderlich überzeugen
kann
[Musik]
das ist natürlich gefährlich weil es
einfach zucker hat weil es cremig ist
aber es verschwindet sofort im mund also
die das heißt es tanzen geschmacks darum
bleiben gar nicht da schon erschreckend
weil auch das haben wir als kinder
lieben gerne im freibad gegessen würde
ich jetzt hier noch drei schichten
schokolade darum machen wir hätten das
erste knacken zwischen unserem 10 wer
das alles total irrelevant
das würde gar keine rolle mehr spielen
billiges eis und knackige schokolade
viele klassiker aus dem langnese
sortiment sind mit dieser kombination
seit jahrzehnten erfolgreich
[Musik]
so auch magnum das angeblich
meistverkaufter es der welt mehr als 1,5
milliarden portionen werden im stammwerk
in heppenheim pro jahr produziert und
alle landen sie am schluss in einem bad
aus schokolade das später für den ganz
speziellen knacks sorgt
in seiner werbung setzt langnese voll
auf das geräusch der schokolade und
nicht auf den geschmack der füllung
[Musik]
extrem prominent gemacht das knacken ist
natürlich auch sehr stark in den
vordergrund gestellt worden weil man
einfach versuchen oder eine
höherpreisige makel zu positionieren da
muss man solche dinge auch öfter spielen
und intensiver spielen der knaack soll
garantiert unverwechselbar sein dafür
hat langnese sogar seine eigene streng
geheime schokoladen rezeptur entwickelt
[Musik]
beim preis ist magnum jedenfalls schon
mal top 9 eur 97 kostet der liter in
einer stichprobe das ist das dreifache
von dem was aldi süd und rewe für ihre
mahnung kopien verlangen
in einem supermarkt will sebastian lege
testen ob verbraucher diesen
preisunterschied wirklich schmecken
können
aber was schmeckt besser das original
oder doch eine günstige kopie
warum
schokolade an weil ja die matten und
schokolade ja in ganz bestimmten dicker
hat und ein sound
wenn man rein beißt
[Musik]
unsere tester konzentrieren sich voll
und ganz auf die schokolade aus nun
[Musik]
das hat aber richtig gekracht war das
eis im inneren spielt dagegen eher eine
nebenrolle
[Musik]
sicher dass ein
bundesprojekt von aldi lidl netto
irgendwas ist ich glaube tatsächlich
dass blaue stimmt genau blau haben wir
das produkt von aldi markiert die test
da sind sich einig in der stichprobe
schneidet es am schlechtesten ab
[Musik]
schlägt das teure markeneis von magnum
auch die zweite billigkonkurrenz
die tester fanden nach dem original
wieder immer noch sagen dass das rote
wäre ich würde bei den roten
hinter der roten markierung steckt die
billigmarke ja von rhede fünf tester
finden dieses eis schmeckt am besten
[Musik]
und das teure lang nie bereist hat es
fans bei sebastians stichprobe im
supermarkt
ich glaube es ist kein glaubst geld ist
das original von knapp struktur farbe
größe so lecker sind wir alle ja auf
jeden fall aber doch das gelbe ich für
auch gelten weil die schokolade fester
ist und das heißt ein ticken dicker ist
als die anderen beiden
tausend ausgenommen
am ende gewinnt das marken rice knapp
mit 8 zu 5 stimmen
der knackt rick sorgt dafür dass
günstiges eis aus kokosfett nur durch
den schoko mantel hochwertig und beliebt
wird madlung und langnese sind so ein
welterfolg geworden
und wenn euch unsere videos gefallen und
ihr nicht genug gehen könnt von unserem
besser es sah dann gibt es hier noch
mehr videos und las amazon abonnieren
-button da ich würde mich freuen bis
bald